[Music]
in dick-pic critic news i think every
girl does that submitted by a banana
potassium stick a semi-professional
dick-pic critic describes her penis
photo rating system Oh what makes her
professional she gets paid get paid for
this [ __ ] so people send her dick pics
and she's like you're like the bad one
oh I bet there are only guys though cuz
guys have this [ __ ] where they're like
is my date big enough like all the
[ __ ] time that's a good thing because
a guy who doesn't know how to send out
proper dick pics needs to send it to a
medium first so she's gonna give that
rating out then that means oh that's
good have you like hit her up huh have
you hit her up before you let's move on
blind like a blind Raider like Anthony
Bourdain where she just goes around and
looks at dick pics like a connoisseur
like Antonia bored dick it sounds like
do you think but if she says that your
dick your penis isn't good enough then
like I wonder if you've nothing you can
do I did a second opinion is it the
anger maybe could be the second opinion
I don't want to be the second opinion so
just second opinion yeah sure that's
true Madeline oh she started she got
filthy eyes she started a tumblr page
back in 2013 called critiques mag dick
pic and she she gets hundreds and
hundreds of dick pics a day
just cuz she set up an email for this
dick blogger mhm
pretty much yeah that's awesome and so
users can pay her twenty five dollars
for a guaranteed review so she knows she
says like immediately when she sees the
dick pics she'll know what's great to
give it immediately but like for her
like the hard thing is to articulate
exactly why she says it's body
positivity so she never actually
critiques the dick itself it's always
about the composition of the photographs
so she's saying that oh we want an
objective review yeah sorry I want to
know about this did you know
that's what that's so she says a lot of
the guys like they hate that part where
because they want to know like it's my
big guy cuz I don't care if my dick
sucks and the pictures good yeah my
dicks not a model I want to know if it
looks scrumptious to a lady
yeah just put like a snack ability at
least chart on it well it yeah it just
seemed crazy to me like so what is she
doing it sounds like she's saying she's
doing one thing and then she's not she
sounds like a bait-and-switch business
you know like you say you're gonna get
you're gonna review a dick pic yeah but
then you just kind of say about the
composition of the photo or whatever now
it sounds like a spam girls we do that
to ourselves just the way we look right
so we never want to take a picture
that's angled bottom up cuz we're gonna
look like a [ __ ] fat yeah so that
means these guys have to do the opposite
if this makes you thinner you just got
to go right under the day so it makes it
look like a [ __ ] giant the border to
do this so what if like okay I'm getting
ready yet to talk to this girl we're on
that that level we're gonna send each
other on nudes right so I'm like okay
cool but before I send it out to this
girl I'm really crushing on I want to
get a second opinion so let's say I take
a picture of my dick
yeah and instead of her critiquing my
dick sure that all you got to get a
better camera like there's not enough
megapixels in the camera that doesn't
help me at all but that's a look at most
Asian thing to critique the camera just
like lighting the pose the tone angle
the framing yeah whatever
this lady sounds lonely to me I'm sorry
too but this lady sounds lonely to me
dude that's a good business idea of
someone to critique it before you send
it I was like what that's crazy because
when I was thinking about this lady I
was thinking like a legit critique like
I want you to take a picture like
there's a standard like thing that that
you have to fill out and you have to
take a picture exactly the same way like
profile this way you can't do no trick
photography and then she tells you if
your dick is dope or not right that's
what I thought it was gonna be joke dope
dicks that's what I want to see dude
don't X dude what about like the Olin
Milsom where your dick is just like like
the mall photography
what's the bridge for dude that's tight
I gotta do that [ __ ] dick right here
and then you have the floating faded out
dick behind you right when it's faced
off to the side like yeah dude my buddy
let me use his dick I don't know played
me told you guys just send out to other
women my buddy Jason Tebow he's a
comedian and he's got a pretty decent
you know rude on him looking so he it's
fun but it's more of a when you saw his
you knew you were like whoa oh yeah you
got a good room baby doesn't even come
to beat like did you guys
he hit me up he needed money actually
he's a money thing he's like dude I'll
give you my dick for ten bucks up up
shop let's not be a very successful
comedian it's up here but he died I'm
assuming this is before the internet
then no this is like about maybe 18
months ago what why don't you just go
get her dick yeah because I don't want
to send something that I don't like
ouch for some yeah some value in you
know so you looked at your guy your
friends Big Ben
yeah paid to look at it though but it
was charity and he offered it's not see
I don't think it's gay if you didn't ask
for it I didn't say it was gay at all
you said it was gay yeah but that's
where you were going for not at all I'm
just trying to get the facts try to get
the facts straight Matt did but yeah it
was ten bucks a pop I got two of them a
cinema and it seemed to be cool yeah 20
bucks yeah because he's more he the
reason is he is more outgoing than I am
in that sense you know it was just look
kind of like an ER like a nervous
[ __ ] dude without a shirt on kind of
as what his dick look like to me were
they like that's not use
here oh it was you get called out it was
old-fashioned like one thigh backdrop
you know what's the backdrop the card
okay yeah like an you could just barely
see the top of his nut so kind of a side
angle I guess I see you know cause a log
shot oh that's like the most common
photo that she gets it's a wooden guy's
just literally just because he wanted to
look big you know what something about
working out though in the lake get
bigger dick look smaller yeah what's
that called I wonder the Houdini weenie
this is one guy that doesn't work out
one leg only he just keeps this a leg
extra thin just for the dick so you lay
on top of it dude somebody said you can
eat you can eat human Nick and uh China
Freck forty bucks yeah you can get human
dead that's a good deal yeah not a bad
day I mean it doesn't seem what would
you pay anything for it to eat I don't
know I think I'm talking about the
payment like if it was my big I want to
get more than 40 but the dead you're
dead though it's obvious yes not
harvested last minute from a dead person
well I like what flavors does it have
that maybe it's like a sexual thing like
you're more like you know Chinese you're
always chasing crazy flavors yeah
they're tired of the flavor hunters that
could be our show in time we should go
shoot that day that'd be so much fun
dude Asian people medicine like when you
look back it it's so [ __ ] funny
because like it's it's so rudimentary
it's [ __ ] hilarious right so it'll be
like this is like I have bad eyes go eat
the eyeball like what how simple was
that you know the fisheye thing right
that's the same thing with dicks right
it's like I have a really weak bigger go
find a tiger and his dick that's the
best solution for everything dude is
city strong
[Laughter]
makes it so kind of up there you know
they don't find like a weak-ass animals
day it's like oh yeah
rabbit dick no - [ __ ] but there are a
lot of Asian people that look like
catfish though and they eat a lot of
catfish that is [ __ ] true didn't like
Dan you become what you want yeah
tilapia is the new Asian right now oh
really there's a lot of age MUOS it look
like tilapia okay tilapia is being eaten
a lot - yeah a little baby little muscle
like that [ __ ] big boy yeah do you
guys ever take photos of your own dicks
no never
do you know how about [ __ ] pictures you
have yeah I did I already sent it but I
don't do anything but you know I was
like everyone says no I didn't say
anything they did you never have ever
sent done why I said dick pictures I
sent myself [ __ ] all you never have you
jacking off my but have you really [ __ ]
hell yeah cuz I had a long-distance
relationship with my girlfriend and
y'all broke up
no no she lives with me now okay
you have to stay together if you send
somebody pictures of you they're doing
all that ass they're [ __ ] they have a
library of me [ __ ] man I have one
where I was [ __ ] beaten up and she's
like yeah I want to see when were you
finish and I'm like all right and I
[ __ ] bust it in the sink for her and
it seemed
cuz I don't I don't know I don't wanna I
don't want to do it in the toilet you
present it's so nasty
we're on your tippy toes yeah dude you
know like that the thing is here no I
have to be on this tippy-toes alright
yeah some Michael Jackson ballet [ __ ]
you know any don't wanna like come over
the faucet you want to come down and
down just [ __ ] funny I just read to
you like about the cup and then you fall
tough and you angled you balanced real
quick cuz you have to let go your heads
real fastball
dude I this should be y'all's [ __ ]
biography this sink is high crazy
I'll get you running and [ __ ] do like
a triple axel it was just she asked me
for that [ __ ] what seat was this yeah
yeah it was at the wheelhouse
okay I never used that one let's eject
they don't know like a nice carpet or
something for your lady come in a sink
for me God be so mad at Jess is like why
the most difficult task ever you [ __ ]
what'd she specify the same trees no I
did it because I didn't want to
associate my nut with the toilet yeah
it's a psychological thing like what
about like a glass of coke yeah whatever
I got a nice plate
my hands were free cuz I was holding a
little serving
yeah present to you l know l nut baby oh
yeah you gotta get your man I didn't
plan hi the sink is high to the silver
[ __ ] platter with like green low
that's the best Asian book ever
this TV gets hot Asians in America and
he's not even Asian dude there's gonna
be a by slant documentary on this [ __ ]
dude he's an Asian is he job nice
Mexican yeah unbelievable
un-fuckin'-believable I think we cracked
it all open we're gonna sink is high we
beat diversity
[Music]